oh did we scare you scared me hello
everybody my name is markiplier and
welcome to the pumpkin carving challenge
with Tyler say hi hi if you're wondering
about the dresses we had no other option
even though we have a natural affinity
to given dresses at the soonest
opportunity we literally had no option
because it was don't look at me like
that they don't think that about me
maybe you well you would you wouldn't
have a natural affinity to jump in that
dress where I live you can order stuff
online and it gets to your door in like
30 minutes uh they only had women's
costumes and it's Halloween mm-hmm
is that a ghost me so we forgot the
timer what time ah ha ha we are gonna be
carving pumpkins but we can't just make
it that easy we've got the ambiance
it's not about safety first kids oh it's
the wheels Wow like also this is this
dress it flows honey oh whoops I lifted
my skin oh you wanted to spin elegantly
ah
whee
mine's just slightly okay back
come over doing alright yeah so there's
the pumpkin carving challenge so the
rule is we each have five minutes to
carve the best pumpkin we can five
minutes is not a long time to make a
good pumpkin or maybe it is I don't know
how long it takes to make a pumpkin so
keep in mind these pumpkins are
completely whole we have not taken
anything there's no she
oh no nothing so we've got our carving
utensil a big one and then we're gonna
make a special surprise at the end and
if you skip the video we'll find guilt
will hunt you down at your home and then
we're gonna carve a jack-o-lantern out
of you yeah so are we ready I think so
I'll be a slight disadvantage because
I'm going to hit the button how about we
get four minutes it's time to it's four
minutes now one yeah yeah been so long
since I frickin carved a pumpkin yeah I
got it first oh you got it first woman
to have it better because my lids gonna
be part of are you freezing your lid
shatter your lid dude this guts on it oh
don't get your pumpkin guts over on my
end of the table I should have probably
left it five minutes because now I'm
rapidly realized oh that's not a big
enough hole damn got a scoop all the
guts out and we're gonna make a punk and
popsicle out of it you're going for
you're going for the the spoon and
whatnot I'm gonna go straight in with my
hands I have sleeves you have sleeves on
a costume that costs twenty bucks
I've got a spooky jack-o'-lantern
already you know it's not for the
competition oh geez we're running out of
time
oh that's hot hot me time
oh the candle burns oh no you idiot
those are some eyes get out there get
yeah here we go oh god he's got a
lopsided up is he's gonna smirk it's
intentional shut up two minutes left
are you serious yeah two minutes left we
got this I got this anyway I don't care
what you got oh man my hands getting so
slippery from the pumpkin guts come on
Oh God my jerking are me really getting
tired Oh God spooky mouth Hey okay whoa
that's cool oh that's actually
legitimately cool Oh 30 seconds left
holy no how about damn it
five seconds
there we go who done hands off okay
house usually
I hate that on purpose see the seeds in
front yeah yeah I got you I got you I've
seen I've seen that before but whoa
that's pretty damn good
all right I know right thank you for
noticing and like the way like entrails
in the inside like makes it look extra
sinister whoa whichever one the
autofocus fixes huh this one by mine
it's it picking me yeah yeah yeah all
right so if you thought we were just
carving a pumpkin huh
[Music]
as you know we like dry ice it's cool
even though the ambience on this one
isn't as good as it could have been but
okay so what we got is we got extra
foamy dish soap and we've got food color
one red one green green makes sense if
yours is sick so this is already mixed
in water mine's a little more
concentrated business you okay
just deal with oh now it's a saggy fly
okay so so what we got here is food
coloring and soap so this already has
water and there's a little water in the
pumpkin not a whole lot but we're gonna
dump the food coloring in Oh looks good
Oh so mine super green oh geez we have
no idea what kind of mess is gonna make
and then we're gonna go me to go get
plates er yeah we should do that
I'm gonna stir it up with my spoon here
to get them nice the soap and the food
dad and mixed together because the
objective here oh my god yours is
already bled everywhere oh oh oh that's
so cool Oh God every when you said
everywhere you meant everywhere oh it's
about to fall off hit a paper towel
right ah run ah I'll make it you're
gonna make it a
jeez you you made it seemed like it was
more imminent than that oh that is so
cool the way it's dripping out the mouth
oh jeez for the record mark went to make
his angry I went to make mine look like
he was sick
originally my plan was to make it look
like mark but I didn't have enough time
yeah that was before we decided on the
time limit yes so now we need dry ice
okay so here's a dry ice
Cheers clinking ooh I see some bubble
work I need that I need to stir my my my
horrific oh god my horrific invention Oh
ooh Oh God
okay so oh that's so cool oh look at the
way mine channels out oh you're still
cool oh yeah you're literally dispute oh
that's so cool I need drastic measures
to be able to make mine come up to you
because it's not working out for me so
I'm gonna steal the ambience a bubble
bubble toil and trouble
something-something belivet II blondie
oh oh oh geez yeah yeah look look at my
I said my oh jeez my oh thank goodness
we put down a cloth oh that's so cool
big okay how do I stop it you're still
all like that the particulate I should
have cleaned this up a bit more before I
did this okay
so after some a fits and starts we
managed to figure out the best way to
make this work so what you got to do is
you got to have a clean pumpkin that's
for sure
and then use a lot of soap a little bit
of water and make sure your mouth is not
so far down
oh it's gonna blow oh wow
okay so uh happy Halloween everybody
happy spook Tober all the world around
forever whoever celebrates that I said
that good super spoopy thanks man it is
spoopy so we hope you enjoyed this we
had a lot of fun even though we had no
idea what we're doing but that's pretty
much everything we do in life so we do
our way through how did you get
online well look at my hand
see it's totally fine by the way but the
sand Oh what if I done how are we gonna
clean this up so anyway I hope you
enjoyed this video you can do this for
yourself obviously only if you want to
make a huge mess don't use as much food
coloring as we did because that was
stupid and also make sure you clean your
pumpkin right because we're all so
stupid so thanks again everybody for
watching and as always we will see you
in the next video bye bye